the simple questions are the hardest
ones to answer what is a thing why do
things happen and why do they happen the
way they do let's try to approach this
step by step what are you made of you
are matter which is made of molecules
which made of atoms and those are made
of elementary particles
but if elementary particles are the
smallest things that exist what are they
made of
to answer a simple question let's start
simply let's wipe the universe clean
away with matter antimatter radiation
particles anything now let's take a
closer look at absolutely nothing what
is empty space is it what we call a
vacuum there are no atoms no matter
nothing is it ready all that empty
nothing gives us the building blocks for
everything in a sense empty space is a
lot like a vast car motion while the
water is very still when nothing is
happening a stiff breeze can create some
serious waves our universe works a lot
like this there are these oceans
everywhere physicists call them fields
this might be strange and new but think
about radiation for example by exciting
what's known as the electromagnetic
field the little kink is created which
is the particle we call the photon the
particle that carries radiation we
perceive it as light this isn't unique
to light every particle in the universe
is made this way there are fields for
every particle of matter all with their
own rules for example along with the
electromagnetic field there is an
electron field everywhere in the
universe and little kinks in that field
are electrons altogether the fields of
our universe can produce 17 particles
which can be divided into three
categories the leptons and the quarks
and the bosons leptons consists of the
electron as well as its cousins muon and
tau particles each has an Associated
neutrino
then there are quarks the quarks are the
nuclear family of particles they're
always found bound together in groups
and pairs and make up protons and
neutrons which make up the nuclei of
atoms together the leptons and quarks
are the matter particles they make up
all the things you see the air you
breathe the Sun that warms you the
computer you're using right now to
distract yourself from the stuff you
should be doing but things don't just
exist they also do stuff in some
philosophical sense the properties of a
thing are just as much a part of it as
existence itself this is where the
bosons and the fields that make them
come into play while the quarks and
leptons are made by matter fields the
bosons are made by force fields we call
a rule of the universe a force and so
far four fundamental forces have been
discovered electromagnetism gravity and
the strong and weak nuclear forces these
forces are the rulebook of a game where
the pieces are particles and the game is
the universe they tell particles what
they can do and how they can do it
bishops move diagonally massless
particles move at the speed of light
Knights can jump gravity attracts the
forces are the rules for help particles
interact which ultimately make them the
rules for help particles assemble into
all the big things we see in the
universe gravity isn't just the rule for
orbits around the Sun or apples falling
from trees as a rule it says matter
attracts which builds planets and stars
electromagnetism isn't just a rule for
magnets attracting or repelling or
electric currents in lightbulbs it
governs all atomic bonds building every
molecule together
forces and particles are sort of like
the Tinkertoys of existence the bosons
are like messengers passed between you
could say connecting the matter
particles which they use to tell each
other how to move each particle uses a
certain set of the forces to interact
with other particles quarks for example
can interact with each other with
electromagnetism and the strong nuclear
force but electrons don't use the strong
force just
electromagnetism the quarks exchange
strong force bosons
communicating the strong nuclear
attraction to each other while the
protons they build exchange particles of
electromagnetism photons with the
electrons thus the quarks end up locked
up in nuclei while the electrons remain
attached by their electric attraction
building atoms even though the universe
has lots of big messy phenomena like
life supernovae and computers that seem
complex on the surface if you zoom in
far enough on anything you just get 17
particles emerging from underlying
fields playing a game
with four rules to summarize in the most
basic form we know right now this is
what things are this theory is what
physicists call the standard model of
particle physics you are basically
nothing more than disturbances on an
ocean that's excited by energy and
guided by forces that make up the rules
of the universe but why and what is a
force we'll have to explore a few more
simple questions to get to the bottom of
this
we made some wallpapers from some of the
graphics in this video you can get them
on patreon.com if you want to help us
make more videos you can do so there we
really appreciate your support while you
decide here are some more videos we made